big
wave there look who it is there he
is the new star of harry saint-germain
lionel messi giving a big wave if you
can hear the fans
can't get enough of it he only landed a
few minutes ago
at paris's le bourget airport
there he is wearing a paris t-shirt and
this only of course coming
just a few hours there he is giving a
wave and
retreating now but there he is the fans
were waiting for him
and uh he has greeted them this 4 34
year old superstar
of barcelona who announced of course
that
he was leaving with great regrets at the
weekend
and a confirmation coming mid-morning
that he had in fact
signed for paris saint-germain which
many had
expected so he wept on sunday didn't he
as he
said farewell to his boyhood team after
barcelona said it could no longer afford
to keep him because of
laliga's fair play rules but
there he is now in france and
confirmation
he will start the next phase of his
career
at paris saint-germain in fans
were there at the bourgeois airport and
they are absolutely
delighted